in this video i'm going to show you how
to add texture and visual interest to
your animated type
[Music]
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science and in today's video i'm going
to show you how to take animated type
and make it more cinematic by adding
after effects effects to create texture
okay so here we are inside of after
effects and i've created a new
composition retro type 1080 by 1080. i
want to make this an instagram social
media post so i'm doing a square 1080 by
1080 24 frames per second and duration
of three seconds click ok
and i'm actually going to go ahead and
start with a new solid background layer
and because we're going to do this more
in a retro style i don't want like a
solid deep black i want to have more of
a bluish black which i have here so i
found that this is a nice color i like
click ok and we'll call this
background
and next thing we do is we need some
types we'll take our type tool and we're
going to click
here and just type in retro and this is
not the typeface i want but i found that
i liked one for
den
this is a favorite typeface of mine that
i like to use a lot of times i'm also
going to
go ahead and click this faux bold to
make the type just a little bit
more bold let's make it a lot bigger
let's go up to like maybe 300
and we're going to align it center and
vertically as well let's actually go
ahead and increase the size of this to
[Music]
and let's make the color
more in that white range something like
this
and
hit r for rotation
set a keyframe and we're gonna go two
seconds down and set a revolution of one
so we have this
and it looks terrible because we need to
get that anchor point in the middle
there's a lot of different ways you can
do this i personally like to use anchor
point mover
from ae juice but there's a lot of these
you just want to center that anchor
point up in the middle there and now if
i preview it we've got a nice rotation
so i'm going to take both these
keyframes now and i'm going to right
click and say keyframe assistant easy
ease
it'll ease into that rotation and then
ease out the rotation as well
and with those two keyframes selected
i'm gonna go into my graph editor here
and i'm just going to
bring these in just a little bit
so it looks pretty good and we're going
to go ahead and
make this end right here
and the next thing we're going to do
is just shift and hit t for opacity
and we're going to set keyframes here so
that
we can have a fade in and out to create
a loop so
we'll go one two three four five okay
perfect and we'll set keyframes at the
beginning
we want to be zero and we'll go one two
three four five
i'm just hitting page up and down
to create
to move forward and backward to frame by
frame uh so our animation is almost
complete last thing we need to do here
is select our type and go up to effect
time and we're going to use echo
and
echo creates just like we see here these
echoes so we're going to do is change
the number of echoes to
18
and we're going to
add a decay of 0.8
and let's set this to
screen as well
and now if you watch this
we've got this really cool
echo effect happening
so one more step here to to complete the
animation is let's go ahead and
duplicate retro
and we're going to take the the color
from the solid which was
right here so double click command c to
copy
and go up to this top layer here
select all and change the color
to the same color as the background and
we're going to turn off echoes and we're
also going to turn off
any keyframes
and we'll preview this now and we've got
some interesting looking
animation
that could be on social media you see
this kind of stuff all the time
and uh looks really cool right so how
can we take this a step further we're
gonna add texture to this to really make
this a lot more cinematic uh and
visually
interesting to look at so when i go to
layer new adjustment layer and this
layer we're going to call effects
and we're going to start with an effect
i always love to use which is under blur
and sharpen
fastbox blur
and what this is doing is just giving us
a little bit softer edge
so
we typically want a value between one
and three so two feels like too much
1.5 is not bad
one let's go to 1.5 and we'll call it
good for that next thing we're going to
do is go into effect noise and grain
noise
this is always a great effect to use
to really blend things together 10 is
going to work just fine then we're going
to go into effect
stylize
glow and to this we're going to turn up
the radius to
100 so it's wider and we're going to
crank up the
amount to about 1.5 just like that looks
nice and the next effect we're going to
add here for some more texture is under
simulation
cc
ball action
right here
and you know off the top this looks like
why would you add this like adding all
these crazy little balls here what we're
gonna do is just turn down the grid
spacing to one so it's very small and
we're gonna take the ball size down to
50 and it creates this almost half tone
effect like we see here
and for our final effect we're going to
go up to effect
and we're going to go down here to noise
and grain fractal noise and we're just
going to create some interesting
specs that happen on screen here so
we'll keep this contrast we'll take up
to 400
brightness negative 200 and let's take
the
size
down to
75
and it's very very subtle here right
just some little tiny specks but if we
go in to our evolution if we alter
option click on random seed and then
type in random 10 000.
now we're going to have something that
looks like
film dust
happening on screen and we can see there
it's looking really cool right so we had
that really basic text animation that
now looks super retro so the final thing
i want to do here
is when we added that ball action it
really darkened up this piece so let's
go into effect color correction and
let's go into our exposure
and let's go ahead and bring exposure up
maybe
five i come in here and i turn exposure
off and i turn ball action off
and fractal noise one thing i want to
look at here with fractal noise is
blending mode if i set this to
screen now i think if i turn exposure
off
or turn the exposure on but let's crank
the value down maybe something like one
maybe two i really dig the vibe here
maybe turn the exposure back down to one
yeah that two was just a little bit too
much
i really like how it kind of blows out
these highlights here
kind of creates even more of a retro
vibe
with those highlights without glow
happening so that my friends is how you
create
more interesting
animation by just adding simple things
that create texture on the piece right
so we went from
what we see here
cool animation
[Music]
uh you know limited in in terms of
cinematic feel
and adding that texture right over the
top gives us a whole different vibe i
hope that you really enjoyed this lesson
as much as i loved teaching it so please
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments below i'd love to answer
them for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro i have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]
you